he was once the world's most famous male
model even his looks were household
names lity greh Magnum and of course
blue steel but that was a long long long
time ago old LeMay we were joke of it i
miss fashions change week the biggest
supermom the whole world is all are you
like a male model or female model all is
all I think he's asking do you have a
hot dog or a bun Derek Zoolander I'm
with Interpol I need your help she's hot
I trust her
someone's trying to kill the world's
most beautiful people o foot so well all
of them died with your signature look
this is bruce team right we need you to
infiltrate the world of high fashion
we're back are you sure Zoolander is all
right now hey handsome
you were amazing I'm sorry I can't
understand a word that you're saying
haha Derek toss me the knife you've got
it
there's only one criminal mastermind who
could be behind all this Prison chase me
I am bad to the core now
talked where's my goddamn latte but how
am I supposed to stop and got to I'm the
mom of a Java I'm if I'd buy you a damn
pop you're Derek Zoolander stopped a
Chinese throwing star with a look
planche me that beautiful Magnum wait
Magnum now maybe we could try a wash
girl yeah fact I she likes Rosario vote
on sook marathi person the same vanish
Pluto